foreign
[Music]
Schultz I am the director of research
and development at cytotherics and we
are a preclinical Cell Therapy company
based in Rochester Minnesota
I'd like to thank the the libraries
organizers for giving us a chance to go
over some of our translational research
efforts with you and today I'm going to
be discussing our development of a novel
bio incubator for the large-scale
production of high quality primary human
hepatocytes
so the the problem that we're attempting
to address is that of liver disease and
that's that's an issue that has resulted
in significant morbidity and mortality
in not only the United States
but also worldwide
and in this country there are almost 5
million adults annually that are
affected by various liver diseases and
these range from acute liver failure
that is
induced either by acetaminophen overdose
or infection with hepatitis viruses to
Chronic conditions that are are brought
on for example by excessive and chronic
intake intake of alcoholic beverages
unfortunately other than receipt of a
liver transplant there there really are
no currently approved therapies that are
available for the the treatment of liver
failure and and therefore there's this
really significant and urgent unmet need
for novel strategies to help these
patients and so unsurprisingly the scale
of liver disease is coupled to this
really incredible societal and economic
cost with liver disease as you can see
here occupying a position within the top
10 most frequent causes of death in the
United States with something like 50 000
deaths per year
um and additionally the burden on
patients should a liver transplant
actually be required
um and an organ that is made available
is really extraordinary with an average
cost of something like approximately a
eight hundred thousand dollars
so the question becomes how can we begin
to address the various causes of liver
disease and one of the path forward
would really be to have a large supply
of very high quality liver cells
uh on which we could one perform really
much needed basic research
um and then also to to use them directly
for for new numerous life-saving
Therapies
um the problem is that there there
really isn't a large supply of high
quality cells uh this just doesn't exist
right now and and the bottleneck uh is
is really a limited availability of
human liver cells otherwise known as
hepatocytes that are available for these
purposes
and there's really a number of issues
that are at play here first and foremost
hepatocytes can't be grown in vitro so
that's outside of the body
um unlike pluripotent stem cells for
example which can be expanded to to
Really astronomical numbers in
industrial bioreactors the same just
just isn't true for hepatocytes
um now the liver itself is remarkable in
the sense that it has this really
extraordinary regenerative capacity uh
and in fact more than half of the liver
can be surgically removed
uh and even then hepatocytes will
regenerate and the liver will will very
quickly grow back to its original size
but
um
despite that fact once those hepatocytes
are removed from the liver their
capacity for regeneration and expansion
essentially drops down to zero and this
is despite Decades of of really trying
to coax them along
so therefore
um as kind of a gold standard much of
basic science research as well as
toxicological and pharmacological
studies
make a heavy use out of primary
hepatocytes that are isolated from
deceased donors and cryopreserve for
on-demand use
but this brings up a second issue and
and that's only
that approximately about nine thousand
livers become available each year that
are that are really suitable for
transplantation
and it's the remaining
non-transplantable organs many of which
are are sub-optimal that are being used
um for hepatocyte isolation and
downstream liver disease research
so so as a result you know these primary
hepatocytes many of which uh have
already been subjected to significant
chronic injury
that's the material that's serving as
this foundation for many of our our
existing research initiatives and and
furthermore there's a significant donor
to donor variability of hepatocytes
which as you can probably imagine causes
numerous problems in our ability to
interpret uh scientific studies that
that make use of those cells
and so there you know there's a number
of alternatives to the use of primary
hepatocytes that that
um different groups have explored
including hepatoma derived cell lines
like
uh Hep g2s and hep3bs
huh-7s and Hep RGS and these are useful
models but despite you know their
convenience at their ease of expansion
and their relatively low cost they
really lack the capacity to perform the
full repertoire
um of functions that are performed by
primary hepatocytes
um
so as you can see on this slide
hepatocytes really are these these
incredibly important and complex cells
that play an integral role in host
metabolism and so
hepatocytes as you can see in this
figure they line the sinusoids of the
liver
they're exposed to a mixture of both
arterial and venous blood supply
that comes from the hepatic artery here
and and the hepatic portal vein
respectively
these then drain eventually into the
central veins and then out of the liver
via the hepatic veins to the the IVC
hepatocytes make up
about 80 percent of the mass of the
liver
and and they're essentially these these
protein secretory machines that produce
the bulk of of just about all proteins
that are present in the blood supply and
and I've just listed a few examples here
but these range from carrier proteins
such as albumin and Alpha feta protein
iron binding proteins such as
transferrin proteolytic factors like
plasminogen
um you've got protease Inhibitors such
as alpha-1 antitrypsin and then numerous
acute phase proteins and and then a
really a host of of blood clotting
factors
um
hepatocytes also really play critical
roles in processes such as lipid and
carbohydrate synthesis and storage
um secretion of bile precursors
um you know these the bio ultimate AIDS
and the digestion of food and then also
the uptake of various important growth
factors
and then finally and most importantly
the hepatocytes are the central sites of
drug metabolism
um and this is where bioactivation and
detoxification reactions uh occur and
they occur mostly in hepatocytes so
things like acetaminophen alcohol
ammonia these are all examples of of
compounds that that really are dealt
with by the hepatocyte and it's it's the
differences in in hepatocyte to
hepatocyte enzyme levels and function
that really serves as the basis for our
inter individual differences in in
responses to to different drug
treatments and variations in toxicity so
uh the the use of these hepatocytes is
really crucial
in the development of new drugs in order
to understand hepatotoxicity and
possible physiological effects of
treatments
um with new drugs
so because of the shortage of supply and
lot to lot variability of primary
hepatocytes originating from deceased
owners there exists a real need for for
large-scale preparations of not only a
consistent Supply but also a clinically
safe supply of primary hepatocytes and
and and these cells would serve like a
hugely important function for small
molecule research and toxicology studies
for example and so here hepatocytes are
are absolutely essential
um for the metabolic profiling that's
associated with with the test items that
are being developed and if it were
possible to provide a really consistent
source of cells with minimal lot to lot
variability that would really provide a
significant advantage to to the
developmental workflow
um furthermore there exists a great need
for hepatocytes for basic Research into
liver-centric diseases such as the
hepatitis viruses HPV and malaria in the
basic researches research involved in in
those diseases
um as I mentioned earlier most of the
cells that are currently available most
of the hepatocytes that are currently
available are derived from tissue that's
obtained from from non-transplantable
organs
and so in some cases these organs are
procured from individuals with
communicable liver diseases
um so it would really be advantageous to
have a a very large Bank of hepatocytes
that have been thoroughly vetted not
only for consistency but but also which
which have clinical safety profiles that
that would really enable us to use these
cells for
um emerging life-saving Technologies
such as liver assist as I've got here or
bioartificial liver systems or for
direct hepatocyte transplant in the
patients and and these are technologies
that that really are currently being
developed as mechanisms to help bridge
patients on the liver transplant waiting
list
providing much needed support
um as they await on the list for for
being matched with a donor
and and finally the ability to produce
hepatocytes at large scales lends itself
to other exciting Technologies in the
gene therapy space in which patients
with rare metabolic liver diseases might
benefit from having their own defective
liver cells removed
corrected using Advanced Gene editing
techniques
expanded to really large numbers and
then returned to that very same patient
as a Curative therapy
but this brings up once again you know
the biggest problem and and challenge
with these cells and and that's namely
that they do not expand in vitro
so it isn't it's not as simple as being
able to grow up hepatocytes to to these
really high densities and and numbers
that are needed for clinical Therapies
I'm just using a stirred tank bioreactor
for instance so so the question is how
can we get around this limitation of
hepatocytes being unable to expand
outside the body
so it turns out there's a there's a very
clever trick that can be used to
regenerate hepatocytes in Vivo and it
stems from research that was done on a
critical enzyme that's involved in the
metabolism of the amino acid tyrosine
and and that's this enzyme called
femoreal acetoacetate hydrolase
uh or fah for short
and so individuals that have genetic
mutations in fah that prevent its
enzymatic activity have have a disease
known as hereditary tyrocinemia type 1.
also known as ht1 and as you can see
here in the bottom of this image where
this dashed line is uh fah catalyzes a
hydrolytic conversion of a hepatotoxic
intermediate so that's this fumarel
acetoacetate into Fumarate and
acetoacetate
and when fah is mutated however
fumarial acetoacetate begins to
accumulate and the patient with ht1 will
eventually begin to develop really
Progressive liver and kidney dysfunction
so it's not Curative but these
complications can effectively be
prevented by treatment with a drug
that's known as ntbc which is actually
inhibiting an enzyme further up the
tyrosine metabolic pathway
HPD here on this diagram and therefore
that present prevents Downstream
accumulation of those toxic metabolites
so an understanding of this pathway is
is really important in that it provides
supporting rationale for introducing
healthy hepatocytes into an FH deficient
liver and then withdrawing ntbc support
and with time the theory would be that
these healthy cells which have
functional copies of fah
would possess a selective growth
advantage over the rest of the FH and
all cells and with time slowly begin to
expand and repopulate the liver
and experiments have demonstrated that
that that actually in fact uh is the
case in in multiple animal models and
importantly it was shown at scale in the
science translational medicine paper
from 2016 that was led by a group at the
Mayo Clinic in which an FH deficient Pig
was created and then engrafted with fah
positive hepatocytes and as you can see
in the immunohist chemistry at right
at a time point two months post cell
transplant and following periods of
cycling the animal on and off ntbc you
begin to see these these islands of fah
positive hepatocytes that begin to
appear in this section taken from the
liver
in which engrafted cells have started to
expand within their surrounding
environment of fah null hepatocytes
and importantly when the authors carry
these animals out to 12 months of age
you can see that that not only did the
animals begin to thrive
um as you can see in these growth charts
at the top right of the screen here for
for pigs two and three but that it was
possible to eventually remove them from
ncbc therapy completely
um as you as it's Illustrated here by
these these gray vertical bars on the
graphs
which represent time periods that ntbc
was administered to the animals
so uh if you're looking at this by 5 uh
150 days post cell transplant you can
see that both of these two fah null pigs
were able to survive off ntbc
and importantly you can also see that
the ht1 phenotype was essentially
completely rescued with significant
reductions in total bilirubin ammonia
tyrosine and succinyl acetone
and so this data together
suggests that wild-type cells had
essentially continued to grow and expand
in these animals to the point that they
had repopulated their liver sufficiently
to cure the pigs of ht1
and indeed when you look at histology
that's taken pre-cell transplant as well
as at a period 12 months post cell
transplant you can see that there's a
significant repopulation of the
individual liver lobules with FH
positive take hepatocytes
so we can use this knowledge as the
basis for being able to expand
hepatocytes in Vivo
and when and we can then take things
step
um another step further and generate two
additional mutations in these animals
and that and that's to knock out their
immune system
um so if we do targeted knockout of rag2
which stands for recombination
activation on Gene 2. that prevents
random assembly of the the variable the
diversity and and joining Gene segments
also known as vdj recombination and that
effectively prevents the ability of the
animal to produce immunoglobulins and
and essentially renders the animals
depleted of B and T cell function
and then you can simultaneously
um knock out NK cell function
by knockout of the interleukin-2
receptor gamma chain or il-2 or gamma
and so these Knockouts of rag2 and il-2
are gamma are used extensively uh in
many animal models over the past few
decades to generate a severe combined
immunodeficiency or or a skid phenotype
and importantly and and this is really
key to the development of our model if
an animal with the previously described
fah knockout
um were to be coupled to the
deficiencies in in rag2 and il2r Gamma
that I just described
um you would generate a triple knockout
animal known as an FRG animal and it
would in theory be able to repopulate
livers with xenotransplanted hepatocytes
um due to its lack of an immune system
so human hepatocytes with a functional
copy of fah would therefore be able to
expand in the livers of these animals as
I've Illustrated in this diagram on the
right
and this has also been done so going
back to 2007 there there were these
really pioneering studies from the
grumpy lab in Oregon that demonstrated
that FRG mice could be generated
and in this nature biotech manuscript on
the left it was shown that after 16
weeks post engraftment with human
appendocites the mice began producing
these really significant levels of human
albumin in their serum
and numerous Studies have been completed
in the meantime using these FRG mices as
really these critically
um important humanized Mouse models that
can be used for the study of human liver
disease
and recently things have been scaled up
by an order of magnitude with a number
of groups having developed an analogous
Effigy ramp model that can also be
effectively repopulated with human
hepatocytes as demonstrated in the
recent paper on the right here uh
published in the last month in
scientific reports
uh in which we're at seven months post
cell transplant are showing circulating
levels of human albumin in some cases at
a really impressive 20 Megs per mil with
histology suggesting greater than 80
percent repopulation with fah positive
human hepatocytes
so here you have two very important
rodent FRG models that currently exist
and demonstrate as proof of principle
that this system for the in Vivo
expansion of human hepatocytes really is
viable
and so
building on these important advances
we're attempting to scale things up even
further with the development of an FRG
Pig
so FRG rodents certainly are useful from
the standpoint of of their small size
their ease of generation
hepatocytes that are produced in those
systems unfortunately face special
challenges for their use in clinical
applications and and this is why we
think that the FRG Pig
that we're developing has a number of
clear advantages for clinical
applications over the the bio incubation
of of human hepatocytes and rodents
so from a regulatory standpoint uh
there's an existing acceptance to the
use of pig derived materials in human
therapies so many of you have likely
seen recent reports on the
xenotransplantation of pig kidneys and
pig hearts into humans
and these experiments are are really
laying the foundation for Research into
the expansion of human liver cells in
pigs for clinical purposes and
additionally and and I'll talk about
this here in a few minutes all of our
FRG pigs will be clones and so that
should help address any regulatory
concerns
uh with genetic drift from natural
breeding and further promote consistency
in cells derived from these animals
and importantly scalability is where the
FRG Pig will really shine so in the
cases of rodents with small livers that
are measured on on the gram scale and
numbers of hepatocytes isolated from
each liver on a magnitude of tens of
millions to hundreds of millions of
cells the really large size of the pig
would theoretically allow us to use its
liver which weighs over a kilogram
uh as a bio incubator to produce greater
than 30 billion healthy cells
um up to maybe an Upward Bound of 100
billion cells in a single isolation so
that's something that would require
hundreds of rodents to even come close
to replicating
and then from a production standpoint
pigs are also beneficial due to their
well-established processes that that
have been refined for for decades as a
result of the use of pigs in food
production so pigs mature extremely
quickly to the size of humans they
produce very large litters and have a
relatively short gestation period of
just under four months
and then finally from a cell
purification standpoint so because human
cells will not repopulate the animal's
liver completely we need to take steps
to ensure that the human hepatocytes can
be isolated with minimal contamination
of of any residual Pig cells that might
remain and so there's obviously concerns
here with the presence of xenoanigens
and and porcine-specific viruses that
are being worked out
um but we really feel that these issues
are further down the road of
addressability in pigs than the use of
rodent derived cells at least in terms
of acceptability for clinical
applications and so we're closely
following guidance from the FDA and
monitoring research that is going to
help us mitigate risks that are involved
in the clinical use of human hepatocytes
that have had both in Vivo and ex-vivo
contact with animal cells
uh so generate generating the FRG Pig
model we worked in collaboration with
Exemplar genetics out of Iowa in the
creation of targeting vectors with the
neomycin resistance cassette to develop
FH at Exon 5 and incorporating it into
aav DJ we infect Pig feel fibroblasts
and then we can expand those cells under
g418 selection and so then resistant
clones are identified
we perform similar rounds of a the
targeting to iteratively create
Knockouts for rag2 Nile to our gamma and
that helps us generate the triple
knockout Pig
and this slide is just simply to show
some PCR based screening that was
performed for the purposes of genotyping
candidate FRG Master fibroblast cell
lines
and you can see here that we've
identified a particular clone that
exhibited the predicted banding patterns
for the disruption of fah il-2 or gamma
and rag2
so we can then take the master FRG
fibroblast cell line and use that in the
process of somatic cell nuclear transfer
to generate our animals and I'm sure
most of you understand this process but
we essentially Source oocytes from
healthy female animals we remove their
nucleus and then through a process of
electrical fusion and activation here
with our FRG master master line
we generate an embryo that contains our
desired FRG genotype
and then these embryos are then
surgically implanted in surrogate
mothers and then a little over three and
a half months later the Clone to FRG
piglets are delivered by C-section
and so we've gone through this process
numerous times now with many litters of
FRG piglets that have been born in the
past year we've got many more on the way
and this slide is just to give you some
brief confirmation that the animals that
are being born have our anticipated
phenotype
um so lack of immune system as you can
see compared to the lymphocyte
populations observed in our wild type
animals you can see the FRG animals are
virtually depleted of CD4 T helper cells
cytotoxic cd8 positive T cells CD3
positive T cells
and CD 21 positive B cells and and this
is just supporting confirmation
um to show that our edits are working as
expected and that we've developed a skid
pig that lacks an immune system
and furthermore liver IHC using an
antibody specific for fah shows that our
wild type animals have livers that are
chock full of hepatocytes standing
positive for fah as you might expect
and then in contrast our FRG animals
have virtually no detectable fah
staining again providing further
confirmation that we've developed a true
FRG Pig
and so one thing that's really
impossible to gloss over here gets back
to the fact that these pigs don't have
an immune system
um
you know with mice and rats it's fairly
straightforward you can you can keep
these animals in small bio bubbles to
prevent them from developing infections
that's a little bit more challenging
when you're talking about a pig that can
weigh over 100 kilograms
so a great deal of our energy has gone
into the creation of a barrier
environment to help us maintain our
delicate FRG animals and really improve
their likelihood of survival
and so we've gone to Really Great
Lengths to ensure that all of our
drinking water is hyperchlorinated and
UV treated our animal feed is gamma
radiated and Halo fogged all of our air
is HEPA filtrated to ensure that that
our FRG pigs are are housed in as
sterile of an environment as possible
furthermore we also limit exposure over
animals as much as possible to personnel
with all of our Animal Care techs our
Veterinary technicians and our
veterinarians they all have to undergo
special testing and gowning procedures
before
interacting with any of our animals
and this essentially repeats exactly
what I just said but here's a picture of
our barrier facility again we really
take great pride in the care of our
animals and and as such we're alac
accredited USDA approved
an FDA compliant and
um again we go to Great Lengths to to
ensure that the pigs are are treated
properly
so the facility itself is just over 20
000 square feet in size and it was
actually purpose built to house pigs
though we underwent a significant
refurbishment recently to help
accommodate the extra requirements that
are necessary to house these FRG animals
and so we have a capacity to produce
over 300 animals in the barrier
environment
and moreover we maintain a closed
recipient recipient High Health breeding
herd inside the facility with females
that serve as our surrogates for Embryo
transfer as part of that cloning process
that I was talking about
a little bit ago
and these are just some pictures from
the inside showing the cleanliness of
the interior of the barrier with a full
surgical Suite to perform
ETS
um on our surrogate females as as well
as eventual C-section delivery FRG
animals when they're ready to be born
um again just some additional pictures
of our production area where we house
the high Health breeding herd our
surgery suite and Recovery area
and then importantly our FRG production
areas where the piglets are initially
housed under heat lamps in birthrights
with 24 7 care
before eventually progressing to sterile
growth pens once they reach a certain
age
so now that I've shown you some
background on our development of the FRG
animal a bit about the challenges that
we've had to overcome in order to
properly house them we've begun to
implant hepatocytes into our FRG piglets
and are starting to begin the process of
monitoring the engraftment and expansion
of these cells and and because the FRG
pigs lack an immune system we're free to
perform both aloe transplant of
pickapatocytes or xenotransplant of
human hepatocytes
um using the powerful selection of fah
positivity
coupled with cycles of ntbc withdrawal
to promote their engraftment and
expansion
and Tamir previous experiments that were
done using the fah null single knockout
Pig we've started some pilot experiments
in which a very small number of wild
type pick hepatocytes were engrafted
into our FRG animals
after a short time we're able to see
histological confirmation that not only
had these cells engrafted
um but had likely expanded within some
of the individual liver lobules
and again that's demonstrated by IHC
using an fah antibody as shown in the
staining here
um and serial histological sections
um really do confirm that despite
repopulation near the edge of this
particular liver the staining likely was
not the result of any Edge effects but
but it likely demonstrates true
engraftment and expansion of wild-type
pig cells within the bioincubator
and we're also just now starting to see
some data coming online where our
techniques of administration of primary
human hepatocytes into the FRG model are
demonstrating clear evidence of
engraftment as you can see here again
with IHC staining against fah
and in this case showing in grafted fah
positive human apatocytes present within
the surrounding fah null parenchyma of
the FRG Pig
so
uh in summary we're still in early but
exciting stages uh in the development of
our model we believe that we're well on
our path toward the use of this new
large animal bioincubation system to
help us produce high quality and
consistently available hepatocytes again
from multiple important purposes
um
and just to summarize what what I've
talked to you about today we've
demonstrated that there's been really
key progress on the path towards our
development of this large animal FRG
model
our FRG pigs are viable and durable
we've got multiple litters that have
been generated by our cloning process
and the Animals kept alive in our
barrier environment for eight plus
months despite their completely
immunodeficient phenotype and finally
we're starting to get to the exciting
part of our our process where we're
starting the beginning stages of
evidence for engraftment and expansion
of fah positive hepatocytes in our FRG
animals
and so in the end our our mission is
clear we have a goal of helping develop
a better treatment option for the almost
five million people in the United States
that are suffering from liver disease
and and we believe that our FRG Pig
model will go a long way to helping
alleviate
the existing donor organ shortage
so thank you very much for your your
time and your attention